[Music]
[Applause] [Applause] [
Music] [Applause] [Music] [
Applause] [Music] [
Applause] [Music] [Music] [
Applause] [Applause
] [
Music]
[Applause]
[Music  ]
[Music]
[Applause] [
Music] [Applause] [
Music] [Applause] [Applause
] [Applause] [Music] [Applause] [Music] [
Applause
] [
Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [
Music]
[Music]
[Applause] [Applause] [
Music] [Applause] [Music] [
Applause] [Music] [
Applause] [Applause] [
Music] [Applause]
[Applause]
None separately
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause] [Applause] [
Music] [Music] [Applause] [Music
] [Applause] [Applause] [Applause] [Applause
] [Applause] [Applause
]
[Applause]
May be true  we will have their
car on the live broadcast,
maybe they can be next to the trees, maybe they
will sound this game [Music] [Music] [Music] I
'm interested in our flags
right in front there
are jams in the front there are children in the front there
are old people there are young people and
they are having difficulties
So that we don't take anyone's right to this Enthusiasm,
can we go back a distance, starting from the back, I'm
asking you as much as possible immediately
[Music] we will
go backwards as much as possible [
Music]
our friends have to take it out they have to take it out the
man who doesn't take anyone away from him [ __ ] you to help each other on this
Can I go as far in Turkish, I
ask all gentlemen and ladies,
live broadcast
[Music]
[Applause] [
Music] [
Applause] [Music] [
Applause] [
Music]
[Applause]
Aleykümselam
[Music] [
Music]
[Music]
[  Music]
I'm so curious you won't come
[Music]
[Applause] [
Music]
our president [
[Applause] [
Music] [
Applause]
[Music]
all together my friends
[Music] [
Applause] [
Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [
Applause] [
Music] you
keep hitting it
sure and my flag
[Music] [
Applause] [
Music]
[Applause]
are you on the air you
were saying live broadcast
[Music]
nothing to do
No, can you do it here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [
Music] [Music] [
Applause] [Music] [Applause] [Music] [
Applause] [Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [
Music] [
Applause] [Music] [
Applause] [Music] [Music] [Music
] [
Applause] [Music
]
[Applause]
more What are you doing
[Applause] [
Music]
[Music]
[  Music]
[Music] [
Music] [
Music] [Music] [
Applause] [Music] [Music] [Music
]
Are there any earthen clamps? Yes,
for God's sake, give me a glass of water
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]  ]
[Music]
[Applause] [
Music]
[Music] [Music] [
Music] [Music] [Music
] [Music] [Music] [Music] [
Applause] [Music] [Applause] [
Music]
[Music] [
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [
Music] [
Applause]
[Music]
because I want to experience all the excitement of Ankara enthusiasm We
will only ask our brothers and sisters who are right at the entrance door, ladies and gentlemen, we have something like this for you.
Since you are waiting in that area, there are
no entrances from the
back
side.  We
continue with our brothers waiting to enter with quick steps and pass to the contractors who are on the right and left. We
held rallies all over Turkey. We
embraced you and our brothers every year.
It was a breath,
so I thank you [
Applause] Did we
blow up the chests
today?
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [
Music] [
Applause] [Music] [
Music] [Music] [
Applause] [Music] [Music] [Applause] [Music] [Music] [
Applause] [
Music]
[Music  ]
[Music]
[Music] [
Music] [
Music]
[Applause] [Music] [Music
] [
Applause] [Music] [Applause] [Music] [Music] [Music] [
Music] [
Applause]
[Music] [
Clap]
[Music]
[Music] [
Music]
[Applause] [Music] [
Music] [Music] [
Applause] [Music] [Applause] [Music
] [
Applause] [Music
Music]
[
Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [
Music] [
Music] [Applause] [Music] [
Applause] [
Applause] [Music] [
Applause] [Music] [Music
]
[Music]
[Music  ]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [
Applause] [
Music] [Applause] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [
Music] [Applause] [Music] [
Applause] [
Music]
[Music] [
Applause]
[Music]
[Music] [
Music]
[Music]
If it was, we
didn't know it, we
didn't twist it Yes, let's share this information.
Look who walks with him,
let the
ferris wheels
spin Hakan, look at the truth, you
3 minutes
Here is the Square, here is the
history Here
is the
Victory, to its chief
Presidential
Love,
all the flags, Come on My Turkey
[Music] [
Music] [
Music]
[Music]
made a beautiful scene  Let's
do it one more time we can
see the music of the mobile phone
[Music]
[Music] [
Music]
waits when it comes on the air we didn't
bend we
never kneeled towards the water we saw what we saw
at the beginning Shadows balance
right
or he didn't give up we didn't leave
the people
[Music] get tired
dud and they
were right dular, based on
both local and national
certain right and
wrong I didn't accidentally
say that it's
a TV series that looks
Turkey
[Music]
[Music] The
sun was born look,
this was calling,
don't give up buttermilk for your loved ones  ]
[Music]
our dear fellow citizens, there
are a few requests All of them are
the same, some of our brothers and sisters, our children
have disappeared,
now I want to inform both families and children.
Let them direct us, we want to
announce to our families who lost their children from here, we
will direct our children to the health tent, please let's
take them from there. At least from now on, let's
not let go of the hand of our little brothers that we brought with us, let these
children not have any trouble, I repeat,
if we have little puppies who lost their parents, there is a
health tent among the trees on the left, according to you,
from your police brothers.  ask for help and they will
direct you to
your family.
Music] [
Music] [Music
]
[Music] [Music] [Music] [Music
] [Music] [Music] [Music] [
Music] [Music
] [Music] my
age
[Music]
was the
world at the right time
[Music]
[  Music] Don't
be fooled by the shot
[Music]
no bits
[Music] [
Music] [Music] [Music
] [Music] [
Music] [Music] [Music] [Music
] [
Music]
[Music]
world world
leaders World
[  Music]
his name is
[Music]
[Music] [Music
]
world world [
Music] [Music] [
Music]
his name is Recep Tayyip Erdoğan [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music
]
[Music]
[Music] [Music] [
Music] [
Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music
]
[Music], which is
sometimes a
companion to the strange, is
a case of calves
in this prayer
[Applause]
[Music]
[  Music]
[Music] what
he believes in
[Music] [
Music] [
Applause]
[Music]
You Don't Know Our Mountains Smile
and see if they break it
every week. Holiday
every day, weddings every day, especially if you
go to the highlands and
you
don't know. You don't know when our people
find love, hearts come closer to the
truth  maybe it won't
show when the veils of the heart are removed
Thank you Turkey has
gained stability The
Turkish nation has
won 85 million
[Applause] He is the
loud voice of the oppressed He is the voice of the oppressed Recep Tayyip Erdoğan, who takes
the power of the silent world as it seems, from the nation,
today
our President
was always giving the number of
participants in the rally areas today 85  million
[Applause]
[Music] [
Music]
In Adıyaman, when we
went to Adıyaman for a rally, there
was a banner, they
welcomed our president with this banner, it
was written on the banner, "What's up, what's
wrong with the water,"  We
thank once again our dear nation who does not need us We thank Ankara We
thank Istanbul We thank Trabzon We thank
Rize We thank
Antalya We thank
Izmir We thank all of Turkey
[Music] is
strong now  I want a voice,
such a strong voice that the
hearts of our wounded people will
be relieved once again
Adana
Adıyaman
Diyarbakır
Elazığ
Gaziantep
Hatay
Kahramanmaraş
Kilis
Malatya
Osmaniye
Şanlıurfa
Don't be Aksun,
hold your head alone, the state is here Recep
Tayyip Erdoğan is here
[Applause]
[Music]
Let's see it, let's see it
close  Let Turkey illuminate once again, we
thank our insightful nation,
thank you for supporting Turkey's 100 years for stability,
thank you for your prayers
Yes
Mashallah, you look magnificent
today, the whole of Turkey is watching here.
I just want to remind you of one thing Today,
not only in the cities of our country, but also in the
republics of Turkey in the Arabian Peninsula
Balcony There are celebrations in the Balkans and in
many European countries
today, today the
oppressed are rejoicing, today Azerbaijan
is rejoicing, today Karabakh is singing
[Applause] [
Music]
Our nation,
Yiğit, said he will walk bravely. He
decided to march again with Recep Tayyip Erdoğan
Thank you Turkey,
you must have a brave stance,
home for the nation  You must have an opinion, you must
have a stance without bowing.
spring has come, it has
written, let the whole world hear it, we have
n't said many words yet
[Music] We
said that the day you get the sign of your youth, you will walk from your father, the nation will walk behind you, and our nation
continues to walk next to the right man,
Thank you Turkey
[Music] what we said in
the squares we said in the
squares  Don't let me
shield your body, this shamelessly
close
will be born. The days he promised you are right
Who knows maybe tomorrow maybe tomorrow I will be
close too
[Music] [
Music]
Our nation made its choice Our nation
chose a lion-like man
Our nation chose a real man Our nation
chose Recep Tayyip Erdogan Thank you
Turkey
[Music]
[Music] [Music]
[Music] rejoice,
my Mehmed begins, even if we
die high, rejoice, even if we come back, don't
think that this wheel will remain on the bump, tomorrow of
course it's ours, of course it's ours, the sun is
born, the sun is up
Let's take a shot from the top camera.
Yes,
85 million hearts are beating together here today.
Democracy has won once again in our country. Today,
our nation has won, our unity, our unity,
our brotherhood
has won
[Music] [
Music]
screens, right?
You are the ones who kept us alive
with your prayers and your support,
thank you very much
[Music] is the
loud voice of the oppressed He is the
free voice of the silent world He is the one who
takes his strength from the nation as it seems He
takes his strength from the nation
Recep Tayyip Erdoğan [
Music] The
dark, the light, the
lies escape from the truth If
the sun is alone  And it
shines light around you. You walk. Chief,
Crows, eagles fly high
[Music]
This bridge of hearts
is not only made by words but by deeds, what happens is
to enter the hearts of our nation, the
adventure of service began in Istanbul
A
Legend was born in Istanbul Metropolitan Municipality, he
became the legendary prime minister  We
said he became the president and enthroned in the hearts of the nation. Legends
speak on the balcony
[Music]
[Music] Let's
see all the flags, let's see them send me
[Music]
We thank our beloved nation for making this wonderful night live. Thank
God, thank
God, for showing us these days.
Yes, let's see all the flags.
You have made our nation live, you have made the world's
oppressed live. Today, everyone is
waiting for our president here today with great devotion and great pride.
Thank you very much
[Music]
young
people,
we want to see your hands now, young people
Mashallah, we
passed the technofest generation,
you know that you are the inspiration of the 100th year of Turkey,
Turkey's century.  he will rise on your shoulders, he will rise on
your shoulders, the architect of the
Turkish century,
our President Recep Tayyip
Erdogan, who has prepared you for this century, our President, Recep Tayyip Erdogan, has been waiting for
our president with great enthusiasm to
embrace our president for 21 years.  We thank you all
[Music]
and this evening we welcome Turkey 100 Years with this election
[Music] [
Music]
I gave everyone a small nation's voice,
what's your heart
[Music] your
values ​​I created the century up
to many times
Immediately  Now, before it's too late, he's
not in his dormitory.
Erdogan
[Music] is the
loud voice of the oppressed He is the free voice of the silent
world He is what he seems,
takes his power from the nation,
Recep Tayyip Erdogan
We want to see Turkish flags come on
[Music] [
Music] He is
[Music] He
always promised,
he didn't turn back from the way he started
He is determined in the case
in the prayers of mothers Recep Tayyip Erdoğan
[Music]
Today
Lovers won.  Let
's turn on the
near lights Let Ankara illuminate the
near lights Let Turkey be illuminated Let the
near lights illuminate the hopes of the oppressed Let the
near lights
illuminate Azerbaijan Let the near lights
shine Karabakh
Recep Tayyip Erdogan and
my donkey Erdogan's Master We
welcome you to the place of experiences We say you are honored
[Music]
everything everything Our
prayers for Turkey
our dreams
[Music] is he
always singing that to the president songs [
Music] [
Music]
For those who don't hear
[Applause]
A  we
love love love
[Music] you
Ask those who ask me
[Music] we
love we love I love [
Music] Isn't
this nation loved?
Applause]
I'm not telling the roads
from the airport to here
Roads Mashallah
crammed
[Applause] You
didn't embarrass the
People's Alliance We Walked the People's Alliance together on this road alone on this road  We
are ready for this,
my dear nation, my
dear citizens watching us at the beginning of their screens,
dear citizens of Ankara
[Applause]
Dear case and fellow travelers,
I greet you with my heartfelt feelings and respectfully. The
second round of the Presidential election is
praiseworthy.  He
entrusted us with another 5 years.
I
congratulate the public personnel, the party representatives, the ballot box officials, the observers, the members of the Police and everyone else who are working to ensure that the
elections are carried out in the healthiest way during this process.
He has already revealed his choice in the legislature by giving the majority of the members of the Assembly to the People's Alliance. With
today's second round election,
our nation's
choice in the presidency, that is, in the executive, has been finalized.
Like every will of our nation, it
has its place on our heads,
but the
winner is not only us,
it is Turkey
[Applause].
If you
remember, we said at every opportunity that
when we win,
no one will lose in our country, we
also said that when we win, the only
losers
in our country will be the
owners of the relevant dirty scenarios and their
apparatus, terrorist organizations and
moneylenders.
Now, we are repeating the same promise here
today,
no one has lost,
all 85 million
of our nation has won.  As a requirement of the responsibility he has given us, we
are no longer angry with anyone.
It is because of the millions being together.
Now,
I am not an accountant here,
but there
is a mistake in the accountant's account
[Applause]
In 2018, the
number of CHP proxies was 146,
we are making the calculation.
As you can see, there is an increase in the number of proxies in 2023,
but
there are rental proxies here.
What did 40 rental deputies do to the parties that received one percent of the vote? He
gave 40 rental deputies,
Mr. Where did he fall
from 129 to 146
to 129 You can't
say which one is bigger than 129, I guess
you can't say Come on, even if you reduce the number of these deputies from 146 to 129,
now
oil lamp  You can take them back and
say come on with a video shot.
But this nation does not
and did not swallow it.
17 deputies have fallen,
what were my brothers saying If you want to take Selo out, you will vote
for me.
this terrorist who caused the death of our brother is selo.
In Turkey, where justice, rights and law prevail  this
is the essence of property, this cannot be changed
[Applause], the
late Menderes said enough is the word, he
opened the doors of a new era.
Behind all the virgins we have lived with since 1950, there
has always been the weakening of this power of Turkey.
It has been destroyed,
our richness, our origin and dissolute
differences,
have been tried to be turned into a reason for disintegration. The
realization of our enormous economic potential has
always been prevented for this reason.
The areas of power and influence in the east, south, north, and west of our country have
always been covered for this reason.
The fear of points is that the
100th year of Turkey, which we always give the good news today, is that the 100th year will come and knock on its doors.
Today is that day. You
are here for him Today, he
gave his life for the sake of the deceased Menderes
Today is the day of reaching the highest level of our democracy and development moves, to the
last breath of the late Özal.  It is the day of the beginning of the process of transforming the
dream of a great Turkey that he has always pursued until today.  We
did it with you
today, it is the
day when the prayers of victory and gratitude for both our citizens and our friends and brothers who see their future with us reached in parts, the
ballot boxes were closed, phone chains
started to flow, they
all expressed their congratulations from the gulf to England and Russia,
and they
will continue their congratulations tomorrow.
we see
all the games played on all the traps set in front of Turkey for the last 10 years,
all the daggers stuck in her back,
all the words stuck in her feet Here is
to prevent this day
German magazines
French magazines
English magazines
didn't put covers to destroy Erdoğan,
didn't they write these covers,
my brothers, they lost too
You have seen the alliances that have been formed against us for months, you have
seen who is with whom, you have seen
who is standing against us from terrorist organizations to deviant raids, you have seen the
dirty games played, but thank God, they did
not succeed, I hope they will not succeed,
because
how strong the foresight of this nation's leaven is,
how strong its foresight is in every
trouble.
He has proven over and over again
and that is why those
who make an effort to find the weakness of the Turkish nation will
still lose.
Even what we have witnessed during the last elections
has shown the honorable stance
of our nation.  There
is no problem that we cannot fix,
now
I thank my Lord for giving birth to me as the son of such a nation
[Applause] My
dear nation, my
dear brothers and sisters,
now that the elections are over, we will devote all our
time
and energy to working, producing works, and
healing the wounds of the 6 February earthquakes, the disaster of the century.
Getting up again,
connecting our people to Life,
will continue to be at the top of our priorities, not
only Our Heart but also
our hands will always remain above the earthquake zone.
Resolving the problems caused by the price increases caused by inflation,
compensating the welfare losses,
is the most urgent topic of the coming days, it
is not a difficult thing for us to solve them
Aren't we the ones who proved it by reducing the interest rate to 4.6 and the inflation by 6.2 during the Prime Ministry?
We
have done this,
but do they have such a problem? No, if we
do fortune-telling with them, we will do it again.
Yes, the interest rate has been reduced to 8 and a half
and you will see it in inflation.
They will descend, they cannot compete with us, they
stand guard at the gate of ayemef.
I said, do you
take your installments?  He
was saying that you still
need to borrow money from ayeme
It is your business, not ours
and look at that day today
10 years have passed We did not borrow money from ayemet
And then our Central bank's foreign exchange
reserve was 27.5 billion dollars
What are
they doing?  They won't give you a penny with a hole,
I know very well to whom the moneylender will give money As
a matter of fact, the
fate of the one who asks money from the usurer has
been revealed in the ballot box, it's that
simple,
and now we
are walking with confident steps, my dear
brothers,
trust and stability, these two concepts are very
important. I have always
talked to my friends about this in politics.  concept, trust and stability,
we will continue with this and we will build a strong
economy management on these two concepts,
we are designing a production economy with an international reputation, financial management, investment and employment,
from industry to energy, the opportunities
provided by our increasing production power in every field will
become the locomotive of a new economic breakthrough that will surprise everyone
we will bring it now, have we
found natural gas in the Black Sea, do we
give it to our citizens for free for a month or do we give it away? Have we announced the decision to give
25 meters of natural
gas for a year
to our citizens as a gift from the presidency
[Applause]
Now,
oil in gabar did not come out
by lying down, it
came out by working more  Before, there
was no oil because the terrorists, with whom Mr. Kemal was in elbow contact, pouring concrete there, but now we did, and the
balances disrupted by global developments are being re-established.  We will
increase our struggle with the terrorist organizations, we will continue
to operate the political and diplomatic channels for more, we
will continue to keep them away from our borders by directing the regional developments in the right way, in short, we will keep them away from our borders,
and what did Mr. Kemal's partners say,
we
will be together with the terrorist organizations in our south.
They took the steps to share with terrorists.
Qamishli is one of them. They
made a joint venture with the coalition forces.
We consider the voluntary return of asylum seekers demanded by our citizens as a part of this policy. At the moment, it is our
duty to meet the expectations of our citizens in this regard with ways and methods befitting our country and our nation.
my brothers and sisters, we have voluntarily returned nearly 600 thousand people,
now we
have cooperated with Qatar, we will ensure the return of
one million more people in a few years with a new Settlement project.  we will
continue to
develop practices that will meet the conditions of the country and the expectations of our young people, especially vocational education
From now on, we will
further strengthen Turkey's pill position by taking it to the global level.
As a matter of fact, Mr. Putin repeated the issue of Turkey, namely
Thrace being a pill zone, in
this congratulatory message.  we
will increase the brand value, we
will implement a system that makes us one of the most important actors of the World Food sector, decreases the input prices in agriculture and animal husbandry, increases the income of the producers, and facilitates consumer access, we
will maintain the momentum we have achieved in tourism, the main income source of our services sector
In short, we will
evaluate every moment of the next period with works and services worthy of a
hundred years in
Turkey.
Emiru
Emiruhanie Melce that secular jace
Konstantiniye will definitely be conquered,
what a great commander and
his soldier is a great soldier.
I believe in you, I
trust you, I hope the 100 Years of Turkey, which we
see these elections as the gateway,
will go down in history as such a turning point.
Yesterday, we said that Turkey is entrusted to us, Turkey and
our nation.
I express my heartfelt gratitude to you for taking care of the
trust.  I would like to
thank each and every one of you for your magnificence, I
commemorate all our martyrs who sacrificed their lives to make this land a homeland and to keep it as a homeland with mercy, I
call our martyrs who marched to death in front of this veteran place on the night of July 15 without blinking their eyes for their independence and future.
You have shown once again that the blessed banner, which he conveyed from hand to hand, will never fall to the ground,
God
bless you all, you
have a nation that gave us another victory,
Happy 100th anniversary of Turkey,
good luck with our great Turkey victory,
I want to end my words with this prayer poem by Arif Nihat Asya,
we are
low voices  Don't
leave the minarets without
prayer, O Allah  Don't let him
resist the enemy, don't
leave us lifeless, my God, don't leave the years
without Ramadan on the roads of tomorrow,
my God, don't
leave the lonely flock or the shepherd  Let there
be Tan from Asia, be
entrusted to God, We thank
our President with good health and for his speeches.
Now we present to you the
esteemed leaders of our People's Alliance.
Erbakan
[Music]
Grand Unity Party Chairman Mr.
Mustafa destici
[Music]
Hüda Par chairman Mr. Zekeriya
Yapıcıoğlu
[Music]
Democratic Left Party Chairman Mr.
Önder Aksakal
and Mr. Sinan
[Applause]
[Music]
We Walked Together on These Roads Together  In
all the songs we listen to now in the rain on the shore where it got wet Everything reminds us of you
[Music]
Memories surrounded us, you were
everywhere
I looked, what's up Let
everything remember me crazy even though I don't want to think about you
[Music] [
Music]
please can you stay where you are please
please
[Music  ] we
thank you very much. We
thank the 85 million people who filled the front of the Presidential Complex today and who are here with their hearts.
Thank you there